えー夜中なんですけども
"フィッシャーズ" のシルクとンダホが遊びに来ております
いないよな？（確認）
大丈夫！（安心）いない×3
まぁ　結構久しぶりにあったわけですよ　彼らに
久しぶりにあったんですけども　ここでちょっと
僕のことを、どれぐらい彼らが 見てるかを、ちょっと検証していきたいと思います
こんな細かいところまで僕のこと見たことある人いないと思うんですけど
僕の特徴として、ホクロがほぼ何処にも無いです
あった(´・ω・`)
んん、基本的にほくろっちゅうほくろが顔にも無いんですけども
そんなほくろの少ない僕を利用して、今回ある検証をしていきたいと思います
下に二人が居るんですけども、僕がここに戻ってくる度に
まぁ、まぁ、どれだけ俺のことを彼らが見てくれてるかという事です。
かんだ(´・ω・`)
いったいほくろが何個目で彼らが気付いてくれるのかっていう
検証をしていきたいと思います。
ニキビができてるから
ニキビを隠す意味を込めて
はい
あ！まって、もうホクロじゃねえじゃん
OK
うん
うわ！
こういう目の下のホクロってなんかエロい
ここにホクロが出来たので、これで行きたいと思います。
では！！
（ﾃﾚﾚﾚｰ!）
うわぁ！（驚
メタナイト
よしっ！
（はじめ）くそ！ちくしょう！
（ンダホ）ああ！ンパンマンはいいやつ
（はじめ、ンダホ）ああ！
まぁ、流石にコレだとわからないことは知ってましたよ
いや、これもう完全に不自然でしょ
もう左右対称みたいになってますから
じゃ、2つで行ってきます
（ﾃﾚﾚﾚｰ！）
（ンダホ）はい～
（ンダホ）怖いっすよ…
（はじめ）怖くない
（はじめ）コレで一回読み込んでみて
（シルク）なんか出来上がったぞ
（はじめ）できてなかったら詰み
（シルク）詰みこわっｗ
やばいなバレないなコレ、どうしよう
ちょっとわかりやすく鼻とかに増やしとこう
ほい
コレは流石に気づくと思います
じゃ、行ってきます
（ﾃﾚﾚﾚｰ！）
（ンダホ）はい～
（ンダホ）美味い
（ﾃﾚﾚﾚｰ！）
もう慣れてきたっしょ？
（シルク）もう慣れてきました
鼻下とかはまずなさそうだから
ニキビ跡に付〜けよ
いや、コレは流石に気づくでしょ
じゃ、戻りますバイバイ
（悲しい音楽）
シルク）ううわww
はじめ）無理なんだけどマジww
シルク）ハハ ヤッターwww
はじめ）無理ーー！！！
気づいてんのかな〜？
でもやっぱ近くで見ると
完全におかしいのはわかるんですよねー
でもまだ、これくらいのホクロの数ならいますよねぇ、わりと
これでいってみましょう。
ンダホ）イェーイ
シルク）うるさい
ンダホ）アァ！！
シルク）www アァww
はじめ）よし
はじめ）スプラトゥーンとかやんないの？
シルク）スプラトゥーン、そうっすね、やった事 あの
"ワ(?)" の時に、ローラーやって奇跡的に下手すぎたんすよ。
はじめ）あ〜ぁ
"はじめの顔を見る"
わかってるに決まってるじゃないですか
シルクは気づいたけど、ンダホは気づいてるか分かんないから
ちょっとどこまでバレずに増やせるか
では引き続き、見ていきましょう。
オッホホｗｗｗｗ
さすがにあの距離ならわかりますよ
でも、ンダホくんなら多分まだバレないと思うのでもうちょっと塗っていきましょう。
７個になりました、うわすげー綺麗な "正三角形" になっちゃった
これで、行ってみます。では！
うおおっ
注意力が散漫だぞっ
今見ましたよね。完全に、目と目があった
このレベルで気づかないってもう何をどうしたらいいんだろう
ちょっと極端に増やしてみますね次
７個で気づかなかったら、多分これも同じことだと思うんで、ちょっとこれでもう一回行ってみます
では！
わああ！！
やるぞ！！
シルク）ウィザード決定でーす
はじめ）ウィザード？OK任せろ！
どうぞ
ぜってぇ倒すからな
はじめ）まだまだまだ
はじめ）アァァ！！　ンダホ）ヤッターー！！
はじめ）ちくしょ、まって×６
次の、次のシルクが選んだやつが俺の本当の最後の切り札！
アアァァ！！！
これでわかんないってどうしたの？
俺もうもうもう やばいって！
これでわかんなかったらもう、おかしいですからね wwww
チーターのコスプレみたいになってますけど
これでわかんなかったらもう、、、、、、、、、、
どうしようもないっす。では
だあ
シルク）これで死ぬよ　はじめ）死ぬしかねぇぞ
もう俺やるしかねぇぞ
これで、勝つか負けるか全てが決まるからな
勝負だ
行こう
wwwww
んん？
というわけで結果は、シルクが５個、ンダホが６４個でした。
シルク＆ンダホ）爆笑　　はじめ）バイバーーイ